I'm trying to remember which one of
these I need to do so last time
inspector was telling us there's no
point at all to these Moody's challenges
Hogwarts exterior I have a feeling we're
gonna need to keep going back to that
one but we are now officially ready to
do the Forbidden Forest we started this
one last time and then just ran out of
time so I have more time today we'll see
how much of this we can get through all
right so let's roll with
let's roll with Harry here
getting a brand new PS2 game just for
the memory card not to read oh man
that's taking me back Mr Moe taking me
back
do you seriously have to reset these
every time that's weird
that is very weird okay I don't really
want to do the creature one I want to do
that one seems pretty cool but you can't
equip another Jinx card that's fine I
want to do two accio cards to make it
really easy to collect the beans
yo waldermar with the five gifted Subs
are you serious
waldermar thank you so much
looks like Dirtbag Got A Gifted right
there
uh Ragin TX Got A Gifted Dave got a
gifted blood render and then the noper
nice the noper Got A Gifted as well
thank you so much Walter Mar so now all
of you guys have at do not have to watch
ads on the channel
and
you also get access to all the emotes so
enjoy
thank you very much Walter Moore
Stargazer Tim here in the house as well
I saw uh I saw Christy in the house
earlier too
Christy with a slightly different name
over here
and then Ray attire that's our boy Nico
guys that's another one with a different
name gifting another sub to Silver 2233
silver good to see you again
good to see you again silver
good question Mr mill first gaming
system Mr Moe's trying to figure out how
old everybody is that's why Mr Moe's
asking that
my first one that I ever owned was an
original NES Nintendo Entertainment
System
the the old school original Nintendo
had a friend my uncle had an Atari
though and then I had another friend
that had an Atari so I remember playing
Ataris as well
but that was not my first system my
first was the NES
I have such a weird path like going back
through my my history of consoles
because I I didn't really stick with one
company I had a Nintendo and then you
would think oh well then you went
you got a Super Nintendo right Super
Nintendo was awesome no I got a Sega
Genesis
and they're like okay well then did you
go in 64. no I I went with PlayStation
after that
but then oh you definitely got a PS2
right no I went with a GameCube after
that
it was a Hungarian I had such an
interesting path
and when I was growing up man like my
family was like
two console what no you were not getting
more than one console
there is no need for that
so that was just that was a definite no
nowadays you know once I was old enough
to have have enough income to buy
buy multiple systems if I wanted
it almost feels strange to be able to be
like oh I can play games on multiple
systems now
hey thank you for the follow and yeah
welcome to all the new Subs man all
these gifted Subs people using twitch
Prime Subs people using tier one Subs
thank you guys very much good to have
you here
Lion King on Super Nintendo oh my gosh
we still have
um
one of the ways I knew my wife laughs
when I tell the story the first time I
ever uh went to her house I saw she had
a Super Nintendo set up in her room
and I was just like oh my gosh
this is a sign
she's actually not like a big big gamer
but but still just seeing that there in
one of the games she had was The Lion
King
okay I feel like there's a way to hit
that little
I don't even know what that is hanging
from the tree a giant Acorn or something
I mean that's what it looks like
so we already started this level
yesterday but then we didn't get all the
way through it so
oh my gosh that one just
dude look at the little cursor I don't
even know if it shows up well on stream
it's just like a terrible
so where I'm aiming this guy over there
by that Crest there is an act There's an
actual like blue
cursor that shows up
but it's like why not pick another color
like a bright white or yellow I mean
so this was the one that we could not
figure up
it's a nest okay you can hit the nest
with the Jinx yo inspector is our
resident
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
expert
good to see you back again inspector
inspector said uh what frustrates them
more than
hold on what was it
you said what frustrates you more than
playing this game is seeing people
have to backtrack or something in the
game
all right so oh no hold on come on Harry
keep keep turning yep yep we want to try
and hit these over here yeah it was
right there
hey we got it and then Dylan gifting a
tier one membership to muggle meets
magic that's right guys muggle meets
magic is Christy from the YouTube
channel
Christy good to see you here this
morning as well and Dylan thank you so
much for gifting Christy the membership
there or the subscription man that's
another thing switching back and forth
you gotta remember to uh the terminology
is a bit different here versus on
over on YouTube
all right inspector
yes you can gift to a specific person
that's right oh my gosh wait we did we
just we got a level three hype train
what
Stargazer how was I not following
that's odd
can you give a prime sub Dave that's a
good I don't think you can gift
a prime sub
I think the only way you can use prime
Subs is like on your like on your own
account I don't think you can gift that
one
all right so
Specter was saying we could
hit that Nest there it is right there
which gives us birdie bought every
flavor beans
which aren't as fun in this game I might
add they're not as fun in this one
yeah that's a really nice feature though
Dylan and Christy the fact that you can
like you could pick a specific person or
it can be random like you can have it
randomized too
Tim you may not have been following
because it's been so long since I had
streamed over here
either backtrack
oh yeah yeah that was it Mary good to
see you here Mary
people wasting time on the game right
mini Shields are affected by accio
mini Shields
most things aren't as fun in this game
indeed right
or 37 there should be a block nearby
that you'll be able to move and get onto
that Shield
okay gotcha there was a wait can I move
hold on maybe one of these can I move
one of these
no wizard doesn't look like it
yo okay dog with the subscription as
well okay dog thank you so much my
friend yeah here it is I bet it's this
one over here
enjoy your ad-free viewing on the
channel
and the emotes okay that one we already
we already did
Guardian Leviosa oh my gosh I didn't
even see that thing over here
okay I do like this power up though that
we unlocked with Harry of being able to
like when he spams this just spamming
random jinxes right here but when he
spams them
it goes in multiple directions now
mini shield on that part can be
attracted by Akio oh
oh my gosh
oh man you gotta be kidding me I was
like mini Shield what are you talking
about mini Shield do I need to uh
I'm thinking Shield like on my character
oh my gosh that was way too simple
there you go inspector already having to
watch me struggle and we're just a few
minutes in
oh yeah the flu Tim oh that's
unfortunate dude yeah I I hope I'm not
coming down with something it's been
going for a few days though but
I was feeling a lot better and I thought
yeah it's just another bout with
allergies but then this morning was so
rough all right there we go we cleared
that path at least we cleared it enough
go this way
here's more of these guys
Doug bugs
take that
oh dude these are huge over here
wait no
is this something different or are they
just larger in this area
let me go
Perfect cast yeah I still have no idea
what what results in a perfect cast
I have no idea
EFA Spartan yeah dude I can't wait
I can't wait
as we
get ever closer to Hogwarts Legacy man
stop playing Harry Potter games after
the third yeah
who is that
I need some help over here
who said that dude
oh wait we we turned on subtitles the
other day
they should still be on but I didn't see
that one pop up
yo middle tier thank you for the follow
if there was a way to play co-op oh like
if they had online support somehow
oh that would be so funny
all right I think we can just
yeah we can just hop up right here
yay that's all good
oh wait what did Owen say about uh
have this little pup with me
Staffordshire Bull Terrier when she
sniffs she sounds like a little pig oh
my goodness
is that character off I mean maybe we're
about to find out
okay I also oh no did I just mess up bye
I feel like we're gonna need that
cauldron at some point
oh goodness
oh yeah we definitely need The Cauldron
I wonder if with The Cauldron weekend
you can break this over here
when guardium Leviosa
blast them Hermione
there we go
combined cast
no idea what I'm doing I'm just spamming
buttons hoping that they help out
all right do we have to Guardian this
guy now
there we go tornado spell whatever that
is
Dragon Keepers trying to catch a horn
tail ah okay
all right I see that Crest over there
yo
all right hold on let me grab this one
the dragon is actually attacking right
now why can I not
why is it not letting me cast
oh no
I think I triggered this scene or
something it's not letting me cast my
guardium
okay I mean let's just go grab this one
up here
I want to get that other one though
I want to get the one over here
foreign
nope
dude why can I not cast
it's not letting me cast it
special things that can't be affected by
spells for this part
would inspector really does know all the
intricacies of this game I love it
all right so we can hit this
and then can I draw them to me
nope
come on come around the corner there
come on beans through the fire
dude we got so many beans with Harry now
more beans more beans
oh my gosh he's right there
all right aguaminty
or no excuse me aqua erecto
because that's what it is for this game
guys
apparently the difference between salt
water and fresh water or something we
were we were discovering last time
stop chasing me
all right get that one Hermione I'm
gonna get this one over here
there we go
okay and then another one just
I finished that one off and then another
one Emer wait what they keep appearing
out of this spot
unlimited beans
Maybe
all right I think they're finally gone
another aqua erecto
K dog I don't know if that was you that
tweeted at me
somebody else tweeted at me with that
exact
with a screenshot yeah
so we'd already heard reports that Sony
was doing that now looks like Xbox is
doing it as well
if he pre-ordered the game on last gen
systems guys with the with the change in
date looks like both Sony and Microsoft
our refunding purchases automatically so
you might need to go in and pre-order
again
but yeah good idea to check on your
pre-order status
oh you had a pre-order for series X and
still got the message that is weird
that is weird
maybe just a mistake then
foreign
gold for current gin so
hopefully we don't have to mention the d
word for for current gin stuff
yeah probably just a mistake with all
the
all the other changes
all right I don't like just this empty
area over here this is weird oh of
course I knew
nothing for me to get over here but just
get attacked
all right
Akio all the beans all right we gotta
help Ron over here Hermione he's kind of
overwhelmed at the moment
just smash them into each other
I don't know what causes the vortex
spell I don't
but whenever whenever it happens it
seems to work pretty well
okay it doesn't look like I can
I'm trying to hit that little Nest up
there but no luck
EFA Spartan I previewed on the S and x
and PS5 got the deluxe and they both
refund him okay that is really
interesting
yeah maybe they're just like doing that
to be safe and just refunding everything
across the board
good morning
keep checking your PS5 pre-order just to
be sure still there so far yeah I
pre-ordered both um
I did hard copy so
I haven't received anything from those
retailers so
probably a little bit not as much up in
the air if it's a hard copy they don't
have to
oh goodness oh dude they just ran into
it and blew it up
oh my gosh Jack don't even say it
don't even say it I think that actually
did happen with a game where it had went
gold and then they still had to delay it
by like an additional week or something
okay
that was fairly recent too I can't
remember what it was though
yeah I would say you're good ggf your if
your date changed
okay let's go ahead and do
what you rock Joe
cracks me up so much
oh wait hold on hold on there's more we
can do over here
yeah I'll pay retract them
all right guys I could use a little help
here
anybody dude the fire does major damage
understandably so but I am at 29 Health
right now
launch that dude over there
oh I see a
what is this a cauldron cake or
something
no
he's chasing me
a Czech and Luna comics
how's it going Luna Comics good to see
you here
thank you all for the follow
ing all right let's cast this right here
launch you over there oh Ron's just
gonna get in the way take the hit for
the team
Ron I need you to just yep yep that's
better Ron stay right there
okay we launched way too far
let's try that again
but thanks to that shift in the camera
angle we did see that there is a
all right where's my there it is
dude the little thing was lined up right
there
okay launch
oh my gosh Ron get out of the way dude
just like come over here come over here
Ron
Hermione yep okay all right good all
right guys here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna we're gonna walk over here
together
come on guys come on come on
come on team team okay there we go all
right now we're gonna walk back over
here
all right both of you are out of the way
now
oh no more of those dudes just came out
no
Maya 648 or Mia thank you for the follow
as well welcome
retract him
let Harry die Hermione will revive you
yeah we I figured I learned that last
time too as long as you have chocolate
frogs
oh my gosh there we go please
no
all right guys get out of the way again
come on get out of the way
all right we gotta launch it again
change our angle ever so slightly
oh my goodness dude this is so tedious
oh I think you got it
yes
all right
well you can see why this game wasn't
one of the uh
was it one of the best Harry Potter
games not one that we look back on too
fondly
oh all right there we go oh another one
of these guys
oh kitties
also just some of the most random spells
for a Harry Potter game
whole new game for you Christy yeah
it's an interesting one
so the general consensus that I've seen
for most people goes the first three are
pretty good whether you're playing PC or
console those are all solid
then Goblet of Fire this was the first
so Goblet of Fire was also on PC but
this was the first one where the PC
version and the console versions were
basically the same
oh my gosh Harry's about to die
but thanks to the power of a chocolate
frog
we also discovered last time guys look
at that meter in the bottom left
ancient magic meter
hold on actually now would be a good
time to do it let's cast our
magical's extremas
not making that up
as you guys can see not making it up
so now our spells are like super powered
or something
so I'm just calling it the ancient magic
meter
who knows dude maybe that's where
Hogwarts Legacy got the idea
[Music]
still think gobbled a prisoner mask ban
on PC
dude the music is like really intense
right now
and there's nothing going on okay wait I
think I see the way I'm supposed to go
now
let's go over here
I think we're gonna get attacked here
watch
[Music]
nope okay no attack I was totally
expecting that we would
pass through there and get attacked all
right what do we have to do here
Carpe retract him on the gate
yep just just stand there and watch guys
I wouldn't help either
it's okay we got it
we got it
so yeah the interesting thing about all
the old games is the way they handled
spell casting
I was gonna say
yeah because in the first games you
actually have wait summon Rewards
is there more rewards that I'm not
seeing right now
yeah so this game moved to the system of
where
can't select a spell it just
whatever you're casting you're just
spamming the button basically whereas in
the first ones you could actually choose
the spell
now the problem with with that is
they're not a lot of buttons on the you
can only map like two of them on console
but then I guess the PC versions
wait on PC versions it was contextual
right like you couldn't
yeah you couldn't choose the Spells
that's one thing I'm really excited
about for Hogwarts Legacy is the fact
that you we can already see
you can cast the Spells apparently
freely at any time you know
all right I still hear the dragon oh my
goodness dude
I do not remember this from the book
Tyler welcome thank you for the follow
PS1 was contextual as well tip for Carpe
retractum AI will not help you with
pulling things unless it's an enemy or
the object requires multiple objects
Gates and tree trunks are one man only
okay
inspector again with the nice tips there
the Lego games are really good GG yeah I
mean if I had to pick
chamber on console is my favorite but
then I would I would say the Lego games
let me summon that over here
oh
my gosh are we gonna get a blast ended
screw
I thought we were gonna get a blast into
screw Dragon Battle there for a second
oh wait can we give this to Hermione oh
Ron just picked one up but
Hermione really needs it only at 18
Health there
only at 18 health
dude there it is oh my gosh
and then there's the there's the crest
up there
all right so it said jinx it from behind
it's like a little boss battle here
don't turn around dude don't mind me
oh that's his front whoops whoops
wait that's it
what the heck just that
inspector what was that
what just happened
or was that
I I think Ron took care of it
I think Ron just handled it there
K marks a Redeeming the uh
oh no wait who was it somebody redeemed
to hydrate Jose redeeming to hydrate
Prisoner of Azkaban give me nightmares
no
what uh what gave you nightmares about
it Luna
sit three a good to see you over here as
well citrae
I know dude that was I don't even know
what happened
I saw Ron I think it was Ron cast aqua
erecto
and then this route was done
I was expecting like a you know a boss
meter and
nope we're just we're just done that's
it
oh is it time for the first task though
we'll see we'll see how the the
mechanics of that work I I played
through
I'm pretty sure I beat this game as a
kid
but I clearly do not have a very good
memory of it at all wait what
okay that's so annoying it just
literally gave me the
hey Triwizard task is coming up
and now you have no not yet you have to
unlock two more tri-wizard Shields
so you have to replay never played this
game guessing it doesn't have the hole
and no Jack that I think that was
people's biggest frustration because
they were clearly on that path with the
first three games like they had an
explorable Hogwarts even if it wasn't
you know huge didn't have everything but
still
and then they just totally went away
from that for this I mean this level
select system not only a level select
system but a system where you have to go
back
you have to replay
other previous levels to get these
tri-wizard Shields as you see here
before you can progress to the next
location even though the story said hey
here you go
oh wait what
oh
oh inspector okay
okay there we go I was like that makes
no sense if they just showed me the
cutscene for this story moment and then
I can't do that yet
all right gotcha
thank you guys
[Applause]
yeah and then they brought it back in
five right or all they did they did
laughs
all right let's see what the flight
mechanics are like here see if they're
any good
thanks are any good in this game
okay
it is inverted controls
[Music]
hold on can I change that
nope okay didn't expect I'd be able to
oh no no
collect beans to improve your score
foreign
dude the game did not look this good
originally guys this is like
oh no
I'm
it's inverted I'd prefer it to be
non-inverted
[Music]
okay there we go oh my goodness speed
boost for that one
yeah this is the Dolphin Emulator
working its magic to make this game look
a lot better
oh here he comes here he comes dude
hopefully this is just a fun
oh no wait am I being timed okay it's
counting up though it's not counting
down
hey welcome to the new follows guys kid
killmonger welcome
[Music]
oh no oh my gosh the inverted controls
are just throwing me off completely
all right let's see there we go
no no no no no the other way the other
way
true story I used to be an inverted
player
[Music]
used to be an inverted player even for
like Shooters and stuff for a long long
time
and then
I play this is this is true story This
is Gonna sound bizarre
I may have told the story on a stream
before
it's gonna sound so bizarre but I during
2020 my son and I played a ton of animal
crossing
a ton I mean we played the game so much
and in that game when you're like
rearranging your house and stuff and
you're doing your
Island customization and all that
the controls are
they're this weird it's like horizontal
is inverted
but
your vertical is not
and I just got so used to doing that
then when I went back and tried to play
other like third person shooters
regular first-person shooters it felt so
weird to me
I'm not making that up Animal Crossing
you think it would be like a shooter
game right that made me change no Animal
Crossing and so now like I I had to
relearn I had to relearn so now I'm a
quote unquote normal
player when it comes to the right stick
[Music]
but it took me a while to relearn it
go
and now of course when that inverted
when my brain thinking in inverted terms
would have been helpful
I'm all about normal now
oh dude I'm down to 40 Health that's
actually not good
I do not want to repeat this
I really do not want to repeat this I
don't even care about the score I just
want to beat it
and I feel like if I die
I feel like if I die it's gonna make me
repeat
man Honestly though like even wait how
did I get down to 20 Hills oh I'm at 10.
oh no
I'm just gonna stay away from the fire
just gonna play it really safe
I don't even care if we go slow
okay another cutscene
oh
there we go and we got two shields for
it silver hey not bad
I'll take that because two Shields is
how many we need I love that just ends
it's just it's just this abrupt boom
it's done
just just randomly that's it
now this is Fox race
I used to play a ton of that game too on
the N64
I have no idea if that game reviewed
well or not I don't even care my friends
and I had so much fun with that episode
one racer game
speed up on your own oh good yeah I
didn't need to speed up
[Music]
I just wanted to be caught okay now we
get a little cutscene got it
but yeah flying through K marks made me
think like when we actually can just fly
around Hogwarts like Alan was talking
about how much fun they have just
hopping on the Broom
follower things a bit Broken Oh The
Scroll thing Dave
oh yeah
showing bits in there
what in the world
yeah so it's still showing oh thank you
dude yeah it's still showing followers
but there's also like a random bit
a random bit showing in there at the
front too
but uh looks like Coral just followed
the channel as well welcome Coral thank
you and then rossi450 with the twitch
Prime subscription Rossi thank you so
much my friend
enjoy the ad-free viewing and the emotes
see I'm gonna add that to my list though
Dave
all right so this would be the follower
scroll showing bits
question mark
why would that be happening
all right so another hydrate redeemed
from Dylan
remember it being really difficult
Dylan loved racer revenge on the PS2 oh
I don't think I played that one the one
we played was on
on the N64 pretty sure it was just
called episode one
racer or something like that
all right so task number one is complete
uh we still have prefix bathroom
herbology
try wizard task number two
does it just go straight into the third
task
and then Voldemort all right
so let's go ahead and do prefix bathroom
two different pod racing games gotcha
uh oh inspectors warning us here oh this
is not good oh wait we forgot to uh we
could buy some more of those cards
her biology level is the worst I
remember the second task being kind of
annoying too
but inspector says the bathroom level
second least favorite level the worst
one comes after it
I thought I remembered the
hold on is that task number two
Let's see we got bathroom oh no
herbology so herbology is a rough one
all right
I'm prepared for it I'm prepared I have
all of you here to help me get through
it
so bizarre
it's like this little music box or
something I
don't get it
all right let's go for the most
expensive one here Aries Jinx will break
up in midair and fall to the ground as a
number of smaller Jinx shots Card cannot
be combined
all right it's fine whatever
when Harry stands next to a friend with
the same card their stamina will be
replenished
okay
so I continue to say like there were
some good ideas in this game I feel like
they had some good ideas
yeah I'm just I'm just gonna buy
I don't even know if you get anything I
it's like I feel like there's trophies
or something
if I was playing it on Playstation man I
won all the trophies but
I don't even know why I care about doing
it on here and they didn't even make it
fun like the uh the other wizard cards
and the other games
all right we still got 186 we'll just go
ahead and buy this one I probably should
start applying some of those and make
these fights go quicker
all right so down to 96 that's good for
now
and then Hermione I need to unlock some
better ones with Hermione because she
all she has right now
are the ones that
I don't really want that one
reminds control of herbivicus is
increased for a short time
now I want to increase the power for
spells there we go is there one I can do
that's more powerful though
okay yeah that one might be good
and then let's see what the 100 one is
all cards in Hermione's hand are
transfigured into stamina cards what
I'm gonna buy it but I'm not gonna use
that one what an awful image by the way
what an all just a horrible moment there
a kojo Mojo with the follow thank you my
friend welcome
all right let's back up I don't even
wanna I I honestly like I don't think
I'm gonna buy the cards anymore
I just want to get through the I don't
think I'm even gonna worry about the
beans either all right so we can't go to
herbology yet but we can do the prefix
bathroom star Geezer Tim with the tier
one subscription a stargazer Tim thank
you my friend
thank you so much for being a member of
House wrecking tour
both here and over on YouTube
Stargazer Tim moderator and also uh
moderator over on the Discord as well
guys
so I I'm PR I know a lot of you here are
in the Discord but for any of you who
hold on Words retro words let's back up
back up
for any of you who aren't on the Discord
uh exclamation point Discord in the
Stream we'll get you the info to join
all right let's do this one here that
increases the power of Harry's jinxes
and then I don't even care about the
accio one let's just do stamina oh my
goodness a gold stamina booster yes
please
inspector says As for the cards I just
buy every card available auto fill it
wait how do you autofill
hold on hold on hold on did I miss an
auto oh it's right here
I like that one
maybe it picks the best ones
you know what I'm going with that
inspector
I like the way you think
oh I guess it autofilled for Ron too
let's do it
that works for me
[Music]
Potter
I realize I never thanked you for
tipping about the dragons
the prefix bathroom's not a bad place
for a bath
passwords
Pine fresh
prefix bathroom is it serious they
seriously made an entire level called
the prefix bathroom
like what
Ron's weren't Auto filled oh
his stats were horrible all right I'll
remember to hit it for each one next
time I guess it just brought over what
we had used previously
oh my gosh
oh my God
he loses the egg and has to go find the
egg
well this is kind of cool though
hold on can I hit that from over here
yeah let's go
all right so we gotta throw The Cauldron
okay
oh my gosh
how many times do I have to hit it
well that did it the fact that it's not
the second task it's like no the prefix
bathroom
I mean of all there are plenty of things
in that book you could have made
additional levels on
they're like let's make one where they
have to go
within the walls of Hogwarts into the
piping system
oh my gosh dude you know what this
reminds me of though I'm getting some
like dark souls and bloodborne Vibes of
when you have to like go through the
swamps
go through the sewers
nobody likes those types of levels
but here we are
all right throw cauldron to break pipes
okay
where's our nearest cauldron here it is
we cannot sing up off the ground
right oh I hope we get to I hope they S
I hope they sing that in the game
I hope we get to hear that
Jenny and he brought his friends there
to take the bath
oh my gosh
oh so true
all right I think we can break those two
let's see
yes we can
all right so we've got two paths here
oh my gosh it's just my my nature guys I
know I said I was just gonna ignore the
beans I can't help it
wait can I can I make this jump let's
see
there we go I thought is she just gonna
fall into that hole right there I'd have
been so mad
all right so we're gonna need to use
these right here
break that
just more beans in that one okay what do
we got over here
ballast of Plumbing
oh is this a little mini Shield
collect 10 mini Shields
oh I think we must have gotten one
because it reset
or does that go by level
do they accumulate across the levels
inspector
I feel like they do right
hey Jason thank you for the follow Jason
welcome
dude Hermione getting tired of waiting
all right nothing over here
oh my gosh so many branching paths
so many branching paths let's try to go
this way first
all right so we have another oh
there's one over there
oh no inspector said I won't spoil it
hahaha
inspector said I won't spoil it that
can't be good guys that cannot be good
hey welcome bearded
how's it going
oh nice
there's a shield right there
I need your help right
all right there we go
how's it going Jason
oh wait I recognize that name
I recognize that name
oh wait can we
oh nice
I didn't even know we could do that
all right so let's hop back down
mini show collection is for each level
if you collected six in Hogwarts
exterior there won't be six in the
prefix bathroom or the forest ah each
level you start with zero but when you
replay the levels the count of the mini
Shields remains interesting
dude why are we getting attacked by
these dudes again can we just run from
them come on guys let's just run
just go
let's go I don't even think we have to
fight them
I know the AI is rough
come on there we go
oh my goodness Stargazer Tim
dude
Tim with the five gifted Subs right
there
hey thank you so much Tim
and looks like we had Nate Fox sit Ray
ghost steps uh lager and King Scar all
with the gifteds let's go
welcome to house rack and tour my
friends
enjoy your ad free viewing here on the
channel
and then you also get access to all of
our Channel emotes as well Tim thank you
so much dude
very kind of you
all right let's destroy this right over
here
see if we get anything cool out of that
one nice a mini Shield
Ron there's nothing like these
okay
he never moved though
my gosh you weren't kidding he never
moved she's like Harry I need your help
we just dropped this like right oh darn
it all right I guess we are gonna have
to fight these guys
look look see
and we thought Hogwarts I guess he did
it first
you guys saw that chicken right
look look look there's another one you
thought Hogwarts Legacy did it first
nope
and then they just erupt into beans
if Hogwarts Legacy doesn't transform
them into beans
pre-order canceled dude zero out of ten
oh dude I'm kidding but how hilarious is
that that they they just
for whatever reason you know we're
transfiguring them into chickens and
then they burst into birdie bot Beans
watch watch it's getting close here we
go
he's just a happy little chicken and
then just burst into beans
oh my goodness
yo Harry's dead but he's he's getting
revived he's back
here we go here's another chicken if you
guys missed it watch watch
okay why do these dudes keep
I guess they're endless spawns
this is the last one I'm fighting I'm
leaving now not fighting anymore you
guys
yeah I think they keep spawning I'm gone
though
oh no can we not
oh we're gonna have to get to the other
side I did not want to fight you guys
anymore get away
fried chicken with incendio right if you
could incendio them afterwards oh my
gosh
all right top down
dude why do they keep oh my why do they
keep following
there's so many
so many
Rin Rin yart or Rini art one thank you
for the follow welcome
dude there are so many I feel like we're
gonna have to fight some of them
Drop The Calder on the pipes that's what
I'll try to do what the heck
it exploded in midair
I still do not understand all of the
random spells they decided to invent for
this game
like why did they need pullus
when you literally have yeah see that's
the one I thought we had to drop it on
there yeah they definitely just keep
spawning
oh my gosh
what are you talking about Ron oh can we
destroy those two
secret secret no this game I don't feel
like this game has many secrets
foreign
chicken flavored birdie bot
yeah what happens to them in Hogwarts
Legacy after they
all right all right inspector hasn't led
us wrong yet
you just have to be quick with it
you just have to be super quick
so it doesn't explode in midair
I'm running from these guys
running from them come on guys just run
this is like the Dark Souls method you
know once you've been through a level
five times
Hermione's still at 36 Health we're okay
we're okay
yep just keep running Harry just keep
running dude we'll be okay I promise
we just dropped down right here on this
nope nope we cannot
we cannot so we run
oh we need one of the cauldrons to
explode those
have a good one Christy good to see you
thanks for stopping by
I feel like I just bypassed so much I
feel like I bypassed so much
all right guys time to call upon your
ancient Magic
okay I gotta admit though it actually
does
you definitely feel the damage over here
okay why'd you drop it Hermione
oh she got hit by that
she's getting hit by the
Earl King over there
come on drop it right there
oh I want to see if it if we can drop it
on that fish if anything happens
or maybe we don't need anything to
happen
Harry Potter Wednesday listening while
at work nice
that's right it is it is Wednesday
James will be doing his Wizarding
Wednesday later today
come on Hermione oh there's the egg dude
okay wait let's fight these guys first
yeah I think they are actually a thing
in the HP Universe oh we're getting
burned so bad right now
out
there we go no another one just appeared
oh dude these are transforming into
rabbits
all right so we got that fire put out
why does the fire key come
on all right come on guys we gotta put
this fire out or they're just gonna keep
returning
no
I think when he walks over it
it lights them on fire again
oh my gosh it's when he does that little
okay right now right now right now
okay we got that one
I don't even care about the beans be
quiet about the beans they're overrated
in this game
they're not as fun in this one all right
now
I hope this doesn't end at level right
here
highly doubt Hogwarts Legacy will live
up to this one oh dude if Hogwarts
likely doesn't uh live up to this we got
problems
we got problems guys
okay good I was hoping it wouldn't end
the level oh Hermione just died it's
okay though we've got a chocolate frog
and if you guys didn't know chocolate
frogs have the power of Revival in this
game
all right so now we gotta work our way
back
okay let's see we need to get no I don't
want to fight more of these things
but I think we have to I think we have
to fight them right here
my dog wants out hold on hold on
let me take care of these Fire
Salamanders
all right
takes so long for the flame okay there
we go Flames they're out now maybe nope
nope they're not out
now they're out
there we go okay put this fire out
keeping
yeah keep your expectations in hype low
that hey that if you if you want to keep
your expectations low just play this
right before you play Hogwarts Legacy
and then like hey if if it beats this
you should be happy
if it can improve on this game
oh no the creatures in the next level
we're gonna hate with a passion
I'm dreading it already
all right let's go up here now hop down
I'm getting some like weird audio
feedback too I don't know if it's
something
going on with the game
and just this level or what
I hope it goes away though for the next
one
okay what are we supposed to do right
here
can I walk in this
no
okay hold on is there like a br dude
Harry just floating
oh there it is I see it right there I
think we need to bring that bridge down
here
all right there we go
oh wait Ron just had he had just grabbed
hold of this
it looked like he had
can I not lower this into the water
you're not supposed to get that Shield
yet oh
that's so unfair
need another spell to get that one
gotcha thank you Mia
Mia an inspector oh no
sorry Hermione you just gotta run
need a new spell gotcha
come on guys don't die on the way out
jump
Hermione
doubt okay I'll wait
not gonna wait for that one
oh no right at the exit
the care I have no idea what's going on
with the camera right now either
all right I'll let you out now
she's gonna be back in like five seconds
though
she's gonna be back in five seconds
oh wait what did Dylan say
oh yeah glad you're keeping the
expectations low chocolate frogs have
that power in real life too oh my
goodness maybe you know Lupine he's
always like here eat this it'll help
right
little did we know guys little did we
know
a chocolate frog
done it
Chandler thanks for the follow I missed
that one five minutes ago sorry I missed
that dude welcome
oh my gosh how many are there
oh mini all there
36 counted them myself
every time I every time I hear how many
are there it's the first thing I think
of can I not just run by I just died
again with her might yeah we're just
we're just running just just tank tank
the damage tank the damage 71 we're
still good I don't want to die again but
just come on run
oh my gosh you guys
oh my goodness
this game is at least passable with
Co-op if the other player actually knows
the game I could I could see it being a
lot easier yeah if you had somebody
playing with you
even Madame Pomfrey says to eat
chocolate after the dementor in POA
indeed
maybe that's what I need to help me feel
better today I just need to eat a little
chocolate guys
I don't have any chocolate frogs but
man the ones that you get at Universal
at least when they first opened I don't
know if they've changed it since
but they were huge and just like solid
chocolate not Hollow I mean that thing
was solid chocolate
took a while to eat that whole thing
actually I don't even remember if I
finished it I think part of it might
have melted or something
I still have the little the little
package though I saved a little box that
it came in
all right I think we're gonna have to
replay that level right
because we didn't have enough uh
some of them are quite a bit bigger than
last year right
all right so Moody's challenges Hogwarts
exterior Forbidden Forest task one
yeah we need two more Shields to unlock
the next location
oh no
oh no
I don't care how big they are
there's your impression for today guys
whenever we do our YouTube live streams
if we hit 100 likes we do a random bit
of Harry Potter quote trivia if we get
200 we do a random quote or a random mom
I have to do an impression I should do
Dudley next time 36
66 would last you last year I had 37.
I can hear it in my head right now as
soon as you said oh God
oh God okay so where all right inspector
I'm gonna trust your judgment here where
is the best place oh did I totally talk
over the mermaid song oh my gosh
I totally talked over it
what's my best bet here for easiest path
to getting two more try wizard Shields
I don't even know if they're oh I guess
we could try we got a silver on the task
one for the dragon I don't think it
would be too difficult to get gold even
though the
maybe I have more in the Hogwarts
exterior
because you guys said I need another
spell before I can get that other one
that's right here
valdi's laugh oh my gosh the one when
he's like
something like that
next stream I need you to do Bellatrix I
killed Sirius Black oh I'd have to I
have to practice that one
I'd have to practice that one
she just has that high-pitched shrill
I don't know if I've gotten all the ones
from the Hogwarts exterior is there
anything that tells you if you've gotten
them all because I feel like this would
be the easiest
but we we saw some in
the prefix bathroom we saw at least
because yeah I think we've hit a point
where I can't do the next level at this
point
sing song voice for sure
the actor who played Dudley in the
movies is the grandson of the person who
played the second doctor in Doctor Who
wow
how do I get more spells inspector do I
just have to progress the level
it'll attack
little tyke wants his money he's worth
um
let's try to do it while we think about
it I'm gonna redo the task and see if I
can't
get a gold here
because I I mean I didn't do that great
and I got a silver so I feel like if you
get gold it'll probably give you one
more one more crest
you get the next spell in herbology okay
gotcha all right so I just gotta retrain
here
retrain my my brain here for a second
all right so Up Is Down
all right we're doing so far
so far so good on the beans
oh no I missed the speed one though
I think speed matters too
okay there we go
more beans
that's probably a good question too is
it only beans or does the speed matter
as well
no I went the wrong way
Draco what's up my friend just woke up
but you made it nice
good to see you here
and you said there oh my gosh oh I got
it I got it I got it
you said there was another way to do a
speed boost like manually I'm pressing
every button and I can't get another
speed boost beans just boost the health
oh okay
yo somebody just subscribed
[Music]
I don't see the I don't see the beans
boosting the hell
Draco subscribed hey thank you so much
Draco
enjoy your ad-free viewing and your
emotes
yeah if it's just time
and that will change my Approach on the
next run
oh I missed that speed boost right there
I'm just going for speed boosts when
this pops up
oh yeah we got both of them
no I missed that one though
beans in the task don't do anything time
that matters perfect okay
then I definitely need to figure out
what is the the Boost button pushing
everything
trying the triggers
yeah nothing's happening nothing's
giving me a boost
[Music]
thought it was the beans that matter not
the time I thought they said that more
beans increases your score
I thought that's what they said at the
beginning when I first started
collecting well we're about to find out
we did that one in three minutes
oh we're not done yet that's right
almost I think this is the last stretch
of it
dude what is up with this angle
there we go not bad not bad
we're getting burned please don't die
Harry
oh my gosh we're at 20 Health we're at
10 Health
no
oh that was too close man all right
let's see if we got it
oh no another silver never mind on the
beans been forever since you played the
game oh right there's a dragon
if you mapped it correctly it should be
R1
oh
we only got silver again darn it
I don't know if I want to do that again
maybe I have to hold it down or
something yeah maybe something's not
mapped correctly
you'll get gold if you pass the level
quick for that you have to hold R for
the passive speed up okay maybe I just
need to hold it down
so this was the GameCube version though
so would that be would that be R2 well I
guess it would be r on the GameCube not
Z
all right I can do that I can do that
I'm gonna do that one I'm gonna do it
again if we don't get it this time then
That's it man
now what was our time there 355 or
something
you you need to fly around the castle
and collect as many of The Bean rings as
you can you do not need to worry much
about the time don't worry about flying
through the speed Rings all you need to
do is collect as many beans as you can
you will easily obtain the gold and
collect the egg that will help you in
your next task deal one thank you dude I
oh and there's the there's the speed up
I thought I remembered it saying like
yeah collect beans to improve your score
there it is right there
all right so we are just I'm just gonna
go slow and we are solely focused on
beans here I'm not even gonna aim for
the Rings
thank you
[Music]
Joe the gamer welcome Joe how's it going
oh the trees don't actually hurt you
they just slow you down
at least that one didn't it didn't take
away any of my health
yeah use the Boost rings to increase
your speeds it sounds like all that all
the boot streams are for
[Music]
and I do yeah I definitely can see
holding down our
gives me a speed increase
[Music]
[Music]
I feel like we got quite a few beans
last time but
I don't think I've missed any so far on
this run
there may have been one ring where I
didn't get all of them
so far so good
we're having to replay this level guys
because to progress in this game
you have to collect these tri-wizard
crests
and I've hit a point where to get to the
next level we need two more
so we just finished the prefix bathroom
foreign
yeah I don't think we've missed any game
sounds like such a pain
[Music]
yeah they like I said they they there
were some good ideas here but then
they also just made some really bizarre
decisions and who knows how much of it
had to do with the time crunch these
development Cycles were crazy
because they had to get it out for the
oldest one right there got it nice they
had to get it out in time for the movie
so it was often Rush development
between between the games
but this one was also I'm pretty sure
this was a different this was EA
this was EA games which EA games did
some did the other ones too but I'm
pretty sure it was a completely
different
developer for the first time on this one
as well
[Music]
all right I don't think we missed any
beans guys
so
if we don't get it this time then we
know
we know at speed even though it
literally said right there
collect beans to increase your score
and in the camera angle they they were
going for like a more
cinematic View and just decide no I
didn't mean to go through that
it's okay we still got all the beans
[Music]
all right I think this is it
this one right up here I think is the
last one oh no there's more after that
I believe it's EA London which were
disbanded
we almost missed that one reading the
comment
this one
oh wow still had a lot more I guess I
just used the speed so much
first time through this and the second
time all right that's it right there we
go okay
all right let's see if we got the gold
that time
do you have any Warden
Ed
all right let's go dude okay so now we
just need one more
now we just need one more
oh wow I mean miss you missed that all
these years
all right so we need one more Shield to
be able to progress
yeah yeah I guess you collected your
beans while uh doing speed
EA took over from Goblin fire on under
bigger time crunch needed to use their
own engine yeah they probably I guess
they had to re redo everything
all right so I feel like
Forbidden Forest
so Dragon we're done with that one I'm
not doing that one again prefix bathroom
that one's annoying so I feel like we're
getting we're at Forbidden Forest or I
mean let's just
let's go back to the Hogwarts exterior
but I don't even know if I
they don't even tell you right like they
don't even tell you if
if you can get more crests here do they
oh dude I just don't have good cards for
Ron inspector his stats are still bad
in next year go to the right section
there will be stairs down oh nice nice
okay
all right so we're going to start off
back again eh back yes we are Moody okay
so it does have something that tells you
he says they're still
several Shields to collect at least they
do that
oh wait hold on did I mess up I think I
need to go back up here
go this way
there's that creepy voice again
Mexico
ah here they are right here the stairs
down
what is that voice
that Eerie singing
what is that I know Mary right
it's so strange that is beyond
like what is happening there's like no
explanation the characters don't comment
on it
oh
I see it up there
oh my goodness Harry did you really just
get
Wingardium Leviosa
I think this is what inspector was
talking about yesterday as well to get
to the end of the game how you have to
have so many of the
Shields oh that's gonna be so annoying
I feel like I have to do it the legit
way I don't feel like I can just go and
download a save
bb88 with the uh follow welcome and the
chat there bristolboy88 on YouTube only
managed to catch a few of your live
streams there had no idea you streamed
on Twitch I mean it's just kind of a
it's it's sort of a new slash old thing
Phoebe good to see you here by the way
but yeah I used to stream a lot on
Twitch years ago and then
did the whole thing with um
you know had a lot of extra time on my
hands in the pandemic
but then when I went back to when my job
and everything reopened back I didn't
have time for both and so I decided to
go the YouTube route and have been
posting a lot there
and we'll continue to post a lot there
but I'm I'm looking to bring back more
of the twitch stream so I just happened
to be off work
yesterday and today so I thought you
know what let's do some twitch streams
but yeah I know we have we have a
worldwide audience so I try to I would
love to have a variety of different
stream times for people
because I know it's for a lot of people
are our 8 P.M eastern time on Tuesday
evenings is uh not a good time for a lot
of people so
if in the future we do more of these
I'll try and keep it keep it balanced
okay I must need another spell or
something for this
so I'm just going to keep going
and then Bibi with the twitch Prime
subscription as well yo BB thank you so
much for using your uh Prime
subscription here with us
now you'll get ad-free viewing on the
channel and unlock
all our fun little emotes as well
oh yeah I need to
Jinx all the dark detectors to earn
rewards
wait what are you doing Ron
Ron we got it buddy we got just just
yep yep you want to walk to Ron
no no [ __ ] nope
um
no
yeah okay there you go Ron Ron this way
but this this way look we're gonna walk
around
we're gonna walk over oh oh Hermione
Hermione no Hermione
Hermione
Hermione okay
what is happening
okay yes guys please
oh my goodness
what is this game
what is this game
oh my goodness I think I could have just
kept going it would have been fine but
he's just back there casting it randomly
what are you doing man
what are you doing man
he just like collapses under the block
all right I think we're gonna have to
yep I see the vision I see the vision
gonna have to bring it over here first
so it's the voice that controls them I
just need to speak up louder and just
talk I don't know be be a little bit
nicer right
maybe I gotta move it over here
okay there we go let go all right hop on
nice come on Harry
what
what
okay maybe I don't
climb on top of that I I get it Moody I
get it buddy
see I was thinking I'd just get up here
and then a wingardium it over here and
then climb up
maybe we're supposed to do the other
side
all right back we go
no I don't think you can
you can't wait let's see can I jump up
here no
dealing with the posture check and also
a hydrate
it's got to sit up straight here
you can climb on the ledge by yourself
you need to put the
the cube up
like all the oh you need to just go
ahead and put it all the way up gotcha
come on guys by the power of gray skull
come on
come on
come on oh my goodness we were talking
about pod racing earlier I just had the
random thought of
kid Anakin it's working
it's working
as he lifts it out of the
what was it sand that it was in right
there
exactly K marks it's working
of choice today uh right now I've got
some water and just a regular Coke Zero
and now look look at Ron now now he's
just like nah dude nah
something you guys might actually need a
little help with nah just gonna stand
yep you guys got it you guys got it like
it's it's moving a half inch
every two seconds here but I'm just
gonna okay there we go thank you
Hermione thank you Hermione at least all
right so we also have eight this is a
good sign we also have eight of the mini
ones
okay all right we're just gonna go back
up
just gonna go right back up you know
apparently Wingardium Leviosa when you
cast it it has like this reverse Force
where you're just flung backwards I'm
gonna I'm gonna use the gate for a
little protection here this time oh nope
nope it's still still happening still
happening
still trying to push me off the ledge
Ron Ron we need you buddy we need you
here buddy actually you know what let's
try to get over here on this side no
Harry no no no no no no nope Harry
oh my gosh there we go Hermione Ron all
right Ron buddy get over here
yeah I can see how if you actually had a
co-op like an actual human player
helping you out here get it yeah
yeah
oh my goodness
up we go
and there we go with another Shield
see Mr Moe that's why I knew I had to
stream it if I was gonna get through
this one it had to be a stream 100 had
to be a live stream there was no other
way
no other way to make it happen
I need the humor I need the conversation
with chat as we go through
never played this one BB yeah it's uh
it's something else let me tell you
it even wouldn't be so bad if they
hadn't made it to where you have to
collect these cards on multiple runs
like why not just let me collect the
little cards whatever they're called uh
try wizard Crest trophies I keep
forgetting what they call them why not
just let me go into a level and collect
like all of them in one go
but I feel like to artificially build
the
length of the game they just decided nah
you're just gonna have to go back
you got once you get one that's it okay
now we're
all right apparently uh according to our
resident Goblet of Fire experts here who
have who remember this game
a couple people have already told me
this is the worst level
and unfortunately we need four Shields
at this point to progress
to try wizard task number two
so here we go guys let's buckle up let's
buckle up
uh Sherry or is it s Harry slays
so I have all of the
Philosopher's Stone PC game Chamber of
Secrets console Prisoner of Azkaban
console all of those are on my YouTube
channel and as let's plays
wait can I why can I not do
I guess it just I don't know I don't
know I don't even care about the car
it's Ron sorry you're gonna have bad
stats buddy
Sharon okay gotcha
yeah so we
and then we started live streaming uh
chamber on PC which is different but it
was giving me all sorts of problems so
if I ever do that one again I think it
would just have to be a recording that I
then post as a let's play but this one
I've I knew I was gonna have to stream
this one to be able to get through it
um so Eagle Eye technically I'm on PC
but it's it's the GameCube version
running on uh the Dolphin Emulator
collect new spell book let's go
then we'll be able to get some more of
those crests from the other levels that
we couldn't
hey welcome back Dave anything happened
in the last 40 minutes uh we had to
replay some levels Dave
we had to replay some levels to to go
back and get a few more of the
wait can I just
of course they're not going to give you
the little bubba tuber thing you need
to be able to just walk right over there
because that would be too easy
yeah so all you missed was a little back
tracking now we're in a new level
herbology which I've been told is the
worst level in the game
so we shall see
I played this game as a as a kid
but and I know I know for sure I at
least made it to the second task
so I had to have beaten this level at
some point
all right so where these little guys
here do
all right we can't walk up there I think
we need the new spell book first
so maybe the spell book is gonna be
uh let's see we already came down from
there
all right let's walk over this way
nothing here all right maybe a little
cafe retracting
watch out for the Thorns though guys
Ron just deciding he wants to Chuck a
rock over there
oh there it is
here we go new spells
you watch the ask command videos nice
thank you yeah that those were all like
I really enjoyed all of those
playthroughs Azkaban did start to have a
little bit of um
there were a few frustrations with that
one some of the puzzles
but most of it was just me overthinking
like 10 minis okay restarted that again
all right so there's one down there okay
which spell did we just get
I really should have paid attention
I really should have paid attention
shouldn't I
it's got to be something to do with
herbology right or bivicus okay so what
does that one do does that like grow the
plants or
and can I use it right here I'm thinking
no I'm thinking that would be too easy
if I could just walk down
I think Azkaban will be in Hogwarts
Legacy
hi
I have said yes
like I feel like we might have a mission
where we go there
because on what on these dudes
on what Ron there we go okay nice
all right so it just makes a flower
appear all right
okay
all right so you can cast it up there as
well all right so if I'm right let me
see here can we do anything with it here
I'm guessing no
but I think where we could use it yeah
is right here
no no no no no not that Harry right
there
okay this is what I was thinking
but yeah I hope so see they showed what
I think was pretty clearly Azkaban in
the first reveal trailer for Hogwarts
Legacy
and then they've just been very
hush-hush about it there's been no
mention of like traveling to other
locations even though we know
we know it's in the game like that
you're gonna go to Gringotts I mean we
see that that one they have not shied
away from
but the Azkaban one they they never
explicitly stated it and it just showed
the mentors to be fair which we know so
it could it could just be like a cut
scene that's like the Dementors of
Azkaban and we never actually go there
but I'm gonna hold out hope
say that I hope we go there
in terms of predictions I'm kind of 50
50 on it right now
foreign
yeah they'd have to have a reason for it
right
before the stairs look like a big empty
pot
oh yeah don't worry we'll have to replay
this level a number of times I'm sure
I'm sure we'll have to replay it a
number of times
oh my goodness that thing did major
damage too
over 20 hp it knocked off
oh
foreign
speaking of swamp levels dude
when you think about Harry Potter guys
when you think about all the
possibilities for a Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire game can you imagine
anything more entertaining
than going through the herbology
greenhouse
and having to walk across water
that's that positive
bye
using a spell to create lily pads I
don't know about you guys but I mean I
this this is the first thing that comes
to my mind
oh goodness I'm just gonna try to again
going back to the the Dark Souls method
of ignoring these enemies when we can
alright so this one do I need
oh no we're gonna need Carpe retract
them
but hold on maybe we don't have to get
all the way to the other side
maybe we can do it from right here
I know what a sentence right
are you serious you can't jump that
Harry you can't jump that
give me a break
come on guys see I need your help
I've been stung
where is your spell going Harry
shoot at the
face
not something I want to see so what am I
supposed to do then
I thought that's how we destroyed the
first one
I don't even know anymore
maybe we have to cast the Jinx first and
then oh wait I don't think we can get
over there
all right well we'll just go this way
then
oh that one's a nice wide one right
there okay okay
I knew that was gonna be full of beans
I would love it if Azkaban was just like
a big reveal like once the game actually
comes out you know I mean they're of
course they're keeping stuff hidden they
have to
but like using the Patronus charm and
the fact that they're Dementors in the
game that'd be a great a great thing to
find now on your own as you're playing
through it
all right well one thing that I do
appreciate is that it doesn't reset okay
so we stun him and then we do Carpe
retract them
but now what's happening to us
what
oh no they do I thought they stayed in
there
Lily Pad form
for some reason these went back
yo I do
has a Lizzy
Lizzy Hufflepuff thank you so much for
subscribing there with your
Amazon Prime
very much appreciated
welcome to house wrecking tour now you
unlocked ad-free viewing on the channel
and also all of the fun emos that we
have here to use
it I don't know just like to speculate
right yeah me too
I love the speculation why do you keep
appearing just when I start to
all right so I think we first have to
jinx
and then
oh my gosh I'm gonna have to go down and
fight him
all right he's stunned now there we go
herpivicus okay stun him then herpivicus
there we go
another one
just run by
guys I could use your please Hermione
Ron do something about this
thank you
all right go go go they did say this was
their least favorite level guys
inspector said least favorite level
we can already see signs of why
I don't even know where we're going
I don't even know where wait what what
was the point of this oh wait here we go
our favorite tracked him
inflation
and now we're across all right Seven
health but we made it
oh no
no
what am I supposed to do here
no
the big one distracts them
oh like a giant uh
I don't know I didn't see a big one I'm
not sure what you're talking about
you forgot about that part what have I
done
oh the big flower gotcha gotcha
ask man is where we break Deke
The Menagerie hell self out of prison he
sus and I know it oh my goodness
yeah I don't think we can get by this
right now
so now we gotta go back
there you go there you go get back here
like this
what are you doing to it Hermione
oh Harry's dead oh no we're down to
eight we're down to seven chocolate
frogs now
I don't like this
oh I see the big one that you're talking
about now
I think is relentless
okay I see
but unfortunately okay so some of them
apparently no no they all go away
eventually and you have to keep
recasting this nonsense
I was hoping that it would actually stay
so you wouldn't have to keep redoing it
all right I see the big one over there
I was trying to use it but
you're like gosh oh my gosh yep yep I
know why it's the hated level
I already know
oh I see I see the guy that I have to
launch I should have
the Bubba tuber over there
I missed him earlier
and then we gotta go back to where we
already were
all right come on dude first try watch
nope fail
oh my goodness those things are annoying
all right so come on we gotta get this
one open over here to distract them back
off of me
I don't care
I don't care Ron no aim no aim back over
here
aim back over there at that one Harry
no not this one
okay that's fine though that's fine we
can work with this we could work with
this
move move out of my way
please please hurry and open
yes go
away
stay over there
how long does it last like five seconds
though
okay dude we cleared out part of it oh
dude I was
I was kidding I was kidding it literally
lasts like five seconds
oh my goodness
I was thinking why is this part going by
so fast and there's the why
there's the why after I launched the
Bubba tuber explore the other pads
oh like maybe over to the right
hey Nico with the 100 bit cheer thank
you Nico
thank you for the cheer with the bits
oh my gosh we're gonna lose all our
chocolate frogs on this level I'm
calling it now I'm calling it now
all right let me do this again though
let me let me give me my five seconds of
time that we have here
to run over here
all right so we got that
all right now inspector said we should
explore some of the other lily pads
so I'm gonna go this way
yeah you guys just take all the please
maybe they can actually do some battling
I mean that's fine if they just keep
them off of me like that oh no here
comes one
all right yeah yeah that's fine you just
leave me alone there leave me alone
Moss is what these things are called
all right come on open it up quickly
Jinx all shovels to earn rewards
oh there we go
another mini one
anything we can do here I don't think so
oh he exploded that
we did what I I don't really know what
we did Hermione
I'm not feeling good about where we're
at in this level right now
will be
okay I feel like there's something we
need to destroy
with this
no dude these things do crazy damage too
they can go through the upper level now
gotcha
get me out of here
get me out of here okay thank goodness
these lily pads are still here
gonna have to bring this one back though
and then the ones over here on the left
probably
come on guys just just take the pressure
off of me
don't let him hit me Ron
don't let him hit me
I will open the way for us
please all right here we go there we go
there we go
I knew he was gonna come back
why is he not getting destroyed what am
I missing
he's just still finally there he goes
this is chaos for real and then like as
soon as I take one out there's another
one
ah
I need that potion in Hogwarts Legacy
the The Rock potion
I need that right now to just give me
more defense and then I can just run
through all of this
I mean I'm completely ignoring these
dudes
except when Harry and Erwin Hermione and
Ron aren't anywhere near
like what what is going on right here
what why would you cast Carpe retract
them cast whatever spell is gonna end
these guys please
okay we got this lily pad out
he's casting herbivicus on it
nothing's happening to him and now he's
just back he's just back
oh no there we go all right down to Five
Frogs
cast AKA right where's 8K when you need
it
I would totally learn AK if it would let
me get past these guys easier
foreign
what a nightmare
what a nightmare
I do not want to play this level ever
again
but I have a feeling I have a bad
feeling we we will have to revisit it
I have a really bad feeling
I do I do get a bit of a Star Wars vibe
from the music
I have Vivica
in Lego Harry Potter you need to destroy
the nest to stop them from respawning oh
here's another blast ended screw let's
see if Ron just dominates like he did
the last blast ended screw guys
or if he's completely useless in this
one oh
I'm right here
oh Ron wants in there dude Ron's like
let me handle this
I'm a blast ended screw expert I got
this
every ocean
[Music]
okay so that was the back end
it's always hard to tell with scrutes
okay he's stunned right now
did we get him
did we get him or are there two now
I think we got him this is a new one
no Harry not the Rock
oh yikes
oh my goodness speaking of Chaos
all right Ron you're not living up to
your
the expectations you set with your first
fight with the screw
all right get these rocks out of the way
so we can focus on the scrooot
you know it's bad when you don't even
know if you're like doing the correct
thing
they keep lifting him up and I keep
trying to join him with Harry but
there we go nice Hermione
Hermione got that one
wizard PhD what is up
good morning good afternoon
let's see what time is it for me it's
about 12 30 p.m for me
if you guys don't already know wizard
PhD AKA
proflanet
fellow Hogwarts Legacy Creator Wizarding
World Fan
we're trying to get through it Lynette
we're trying to get through one of the
I mean just just absolute Pinnacles of
Harry Potter gameplay I tell you wow one
of
I am I I can't get over how impressed I
am with this
I played this one as a kid but so much
of this I forgot
for for good reason for good reason I
might add
oh inspector has to go away for a couple
minutes that means we're all blind we're
all blind on what well some of us there
was somebody else uh
oh their name started with an M Mia I
think maybe somebody else who had had
some experience with this game
yeah inspector's been our expert on
all the what should we call them
intricacies of uh this Goblet of Fire
game
oh you never played this one Lynette
I mean I wouldn't recommend it
unless you're just like going for the
completionist which is what I'm doing I
want to play through all of them
but um they just made so many bizarre
changes and we were talking about how
you know change they changed developers
so that probably had a lot to do with it
who knows what the development time was
like in terms of getting it ready for
the movie and everything but they
completely took the first three games
whether you played on PC or console were
all quite Charming I mean they had their
they had their uh they had their flaws
for sure
but they also had a lot of good
qualities as well
Oh I thought I might be able to break
that I don't know what good that did but
but then this one just took everything
they did well and was like eh we're
gonna throw all that out the window
so instead of it actually being like an
open Hogwarts to explore and all that no
they took away all that
and so you progressed through different
levels which are
not the most interesting of levels I was
trying to see if there's a way I could
get up there
because it definitely seems like we're
gonna need to make our way there at some
point
well let's see what happens here it is
does this one give me like a little ramp
or is that wishful thinking
yeah wishful thinking I thought so
I thought it was wishful thinking
watch and learn from a probe no no no no
no
far from it
so good question Eagle Eye this was the
first one where they uh got to be pretty
much the same
so the first three Harry Potter games
were quite different whether you played
on PC or console but this one they were
the same yeah
other than you know your usual like PC
differences like I'm sure it had
oh great here's more of those annoying
things the mosps
oh and he can just like phase in and out
of the of the greenhouse there well
maybe he'll stay in there now yeah just
stay in there dude
just stay in there
the good thing the good thing about this
game
Lynette and anyone else who hasn't
played chocolate frogs
they can revive you who knew
who knew all those years Voldemort was
trying to fight and beat immortality
all the man had to do
was get him a you know yearly supply of
chocolate frogs that's it
you die someone gives you a chocolate
frog you're good you're good that's it
that's all you needed
they are chocolate it'll help all right
what am I missing here guys can we just
is there a way to jump over there oh no
wait we gotta make our way in
sneaky sneaky camera work right there
come on come on too
well just run from in Hermione that is
literally the best strategy against
these things
good not even kidding best strategy if
they had potions in this game I would
cast like some sort of
use a potion that's going to give me a
defense boost and then we are out of
here
come on Harry aim at the little box here
I know it's got beans in it
are you kidding me are you kidding me
you're gonna put this little box up here
and there's no beans come on dude
right yeah all you need is to hoard
chocolate frogs attract him come on Ron
help out
all right now let's use this and Destroy
these little statues
more beans of course
a vivicus they also decided to just
invent a whole bunch of spells for this
one for some reason
there's actually a spell called pullus
for whatever reason instead of accio
they're like pullus and then instead of
aguaminte they cast aqua eructo
I'm not making that up
not making it up all right I guess
there's nothing else I'm supposed to
destroy here
and then we have the early beginnings of
an ancient magic meter if you look there
in the bottom left
all right see look you stun these guys
and then I don't really know what I'm
doing for some reason Harry cast
Carpe retract them
Hermione or somebody's trying to cast
inflatus on it
yes it's the green one that's the one
that I feel like eventually destroys him
why not I I don't understand it I don't
understand some of the spell decisions
in this game
and then like Hermione and Ron they just
sometimes I mean they have a mind of
their own let me tell you
so originally I mean the game is Co-op
like if I had additional controllers and
other people we could play together
you know local co-op of course so that I
think that was kind of their big selling
point their big focus with this one is
they wanted it to be a more
Cooperative experience
oh yeah they pronounce it axio in this
one
they're just like it's axio in this one
aren't there already movies by this
point where they were pronouncing it yes
yes there were
a welcome Bobby love how gaming has come
so far right
dude back then
when we were playing through this
nonsense that's when we were in our
heads we were imagining a game like
Hogwarts Legacy it's what we were
imagining
for some reason these little shovels are
collectibles
all right so these should be fairly
I I spoke too soon I was gonna say
fairly straightforward but for some
reason these dudes have a special power
now my spell doesn't work on them
I want to get that
get that Shield back there
I don't think you're supposed to be over
here this looks like this looks like I'm
kind of glitching here
let me accio you a question
hey Frey dark welcome thank you for the
follow
why is it not
these do look a little different like
they look a little stronger see how
they're they're brown they have a
slightly different coloration
oh yeah see those in there are a little
bit lighter these Bubba tubers
wait wait wait
maybe we need to use our power of
ancient magic or as they call it in this
game
yep there we go
and let's see if it works no
[Applause]
[Music]
did I just miss casting it on the pot
earlier
would my regular spell have destroyed it
or did it literally take the power of
ancient Magic
oh my goodness
I'm so confused as to why that worked
I actually think I think I just needed
to shoot the little pot before
but if it actually required the ancient
Magic
oh my goodness that's too funny ah
Johnny the hustle puff Russell is Frey
dark nice thank you for making your way
over here my friend
yeah it seems like I don't know seems
about 50 50 in terms of people from
YouTube who have a different name over
here
so it'll probably take me a little bit
uh
remember different people's names oh no
not more of those guys
can I just go this way
whoa where are we at
my perspective is thrown off right here
like see these dudes we can launch these
guys
I think we need to go over here though
yeah do that Hermione and Ron just
keep the Wasps off me please
yep that's all you guys got to do just
take damage away from you
away from me
Ned hey Ned thank you for the follow
welcome welcome
yeah so I feel like most of you watching
and hanging out right now probably came
over from the YouTube channel but uh if
not we we do stream regularly on YouTube
which is more like a talk show weekly
talk show on Tuesday evenings instead of
gameplay
right now we're talking all things
Hogwarts Legacy on our weekly stream we
only have four more streams guys
I guess five if you count like the day
the day before it releases
crazy man just crazy
no Harry why would you cast a spell that
does nothing to this dude
great cast though the game says
great cast
come on destroy that thing there we go
and they just erupt in beans
all right here we go
yes take the damage Ron Hermione please
be my Shields
there we go all right
no great of course there's a bunch of
them surrounding our next
our next tri-wizard oh now we've got now
we've got angry red ones
oh no
I'm focusing on him focusing on him
oh this is bad this is bad we should
have we should have definitely saved our
ancient magic for this guys
don't do that what am I supposed to do
Harry
how do we combat them
oh I'm dead that's okay we got five
chocolate frogs left
eat a chocolate frog Harry you're
revived now good good
but we only have four left that's bad
that's very very bad okay the red one
just decided to
go somewhere else for a moment or did we
finally actually
inflatus instead of in gorgio it's
inflatus
Perfect cast
no idea what I'm doing get a purse
you guys know
no idea
wait
and they just keep calming dude they
just keep coming
no
that one burst into fireworks what is
this game
we're almost there we're almost there
though
nice grab some health along the way
Harry
you know what he needs right now is his
invisibility cloak
should have brought your invisibility
cloak would have made this much easier
would have made it much easier
because trust me I would 100 take the
stealth approach
oh look I love how they taunt you with
the camera view they're like look you're
so close
but before you get there
you have to fight more of these annoying
mosques break the fountain with
cauldrons all right
all right that's one oh there's an extra
one
I have another
oh no here come the Moss
I I'm not worried about sprout right now
here in the rules of the TriWest
tournament did it say You must collect
three try was a Crest before you can
compete
in the next challenge
sorry if you see if it seems like I'm
I'm losing a little bit here guys we are
we you know we've hit our Point here
those Earl Kings seems different now no
no just run Harry just get out of here
I don't know what the camera's doing but
I'm running go
get out of my way dude
get out of my way just just run
just run
do you'd imagine they made me go all the
way back up there
maybe it's like a boss battle you have
to defeat the giant one
I don't think so I don't think so
no you guys yes you stay up there
Hermione Ron you all stay up there
you're doing you're doing great
you're doing a great job
yes keep taking the damage
I'm just gonna put out this fire don't
mind me
do not mind me down here great cast see
look the game's even telling you guys
you're doing a great job
doing a great job
all right we got to put out probably all
of the fire
okay can we grab this thing now
oh my God
oh my goodness we got it guys
we finally got it
level up Carpe retract them
all right I need a moment I need a
moment
who am I imitating yeah I got no idea
that was
that was just uh what this game does to
you guys it's what this game does to you
this game's so off the lore I know it
was like they just it was like somebody
said you have one hour to make a goblet
of fire game
go and every idea that was on the wall
they're just just throwing it in there
okay we got these enemies Earl Kings
we've got these uh mosps we're gonna put
them in the herbology level they just
they just bother you constantly and
there's no like real easy way oh do we
need a way to combat them we need a way
to fight them oh
your best defense is to just uh run it's
just run
oh for Gilly weed wasn't worth it
oh dude
uh the magicus extremus or whatever yeah
I think it just makes your spells more
powerful for a bit
just makes them more powerful
all right so we need three more Shields
to unlock the next location oh dude
I do not want to do it in that level
excuse me
two one more all right I think we're
good
ah I think we're good I think we're good
now
try wizard Shields we need three more of
those
but the good news is we did unlock a new
spell
we unlocked a new spell on that one and
I know for sure where another one is in
the prefix bathroom that we can go get
so that would be one more
and then I think there might be there
actually might be two there we've gotten
all of them for the Triwizard task one
and then we might have to do Forbidden
Forest or the Hogwarts exterior again
yeah you called it or you called it
worst level
I'm allergic to Gilly weed
oh man
yeah this morning I woke up with
something I don't know what I'm hoping
it's just allergies but
crazy crazy pressure in my head
all right so let's do the prefix
bathroom
oh no wait before I do that I need I
need an additional
we need some additional power-ups let's
go to the wizard cards
yeah you definitely nailed it on worst
level
definitely nailed it on worst level
pepper up post would be great right
about now
I've been taking some Muggle muggle
potion muggle made potions instead
all right we have not really gotten Ron
too many good things so he's got a lot
of beans to spend
so all right you would think that the
best
all right let's just go ahead and unlock
some of these
more expensive ones for him
I have a voicemail from a random number
okay yeah we'll buy that one sure why
not
just buy every card yeah that's what
I was just gonna go through
buy the most expensive ones and then let
the game decide
I like your idea of doing the the auto
dude we have so many so many with Ron
we're gonna be able to buy quite a few
of these
picture set
it's like let's just find random
screenshots of Goblet of Fire
all right so that sets locked
all right let's go and buy these
oh so Weasley
okay so like that one increases the
duration magicus extremas
term we've never heard
never heard in all of the Wizarding
World
pepper up potion available IRL right
oh I do love that picture that's a good
one
and then this little bizarre music box
that plays when you're here in this area
all right let's buy the 100 one here
and then
a picture of Ron and then by the 21. all
right so now let's go to Hermione's
cards
oh dude she's got a lot too
you now want to play this game oh my
goodness inspector don't do it to
yourself don't do it
my goal is to have to oh dude why would
you choose that picture
come on
one of the saddest moments in the entire
series are you kidding me
all right so let's see if there's any
more expensive on these other Pages oh
yeah I got some 200 ones here let's go
ahead and buy those
do we unlock set five no did not
I love how the music box resets
like listen when I
okay now it's like now we need to reset
again
all right so we still got 200 with
Hermione so we can buy all of this page
cool little throwback if the player
character says magic goes extra bus
no no
please do not do that Hogwarts Legacy do
not
all right we still got 130. we might be
able to buy everything right now with
Hermione that's unlocked
foreign
people who can bear this game at all
while still hating it one of your very
first games on PC oh what were the
controls on PC like or did you play with
a controller
I'd be really curious to see how it
control with mouse and keyboard because
you I mean you have like a little bit of
control over the camera but it's not
much it's like a very limited
all right so we unlocked everything with
Hermione that we have available to us
all right now let's go into Harry's here
he's got 933 so we got all of set one
all of set two all of us or nope not all
of set three
let's go ahead and buy that one get that
out of the way
all right now you got some more
expensive ones here
275. oh we cast three jinxes at a time
oh man we're getting ready for those
mosps
they don't know what's coming
they don't know what's coming guys
with our magicus extremist power
and upgrading all of our spells here
all right nice so we got quite a few
beans left over with Harry
even after doing that oh see I told you
I told you she was going to want back in
I don't know if you guys could hear her
bark
not really that full bark just a little
from the door
hey let me in here
have you thought about reading the Harry
Potter books on stream kind of like a
read-along type thing I think that's
that's a good idea but it's like uh it's
a it's a copyright issue
if you're reading full like the full-on
book on stream yeah if it's something
that's public domain you can do it
and you can do it like you know a quote
or a little passage here and there
but I think the only way to you can do
it on stream is you would have to like
it'd have to be a fair use thing so I
think like teachers and school like
education they're allowed to do it on
certain things
all right so we're just gonna do that oh
my goodness that made his like is it
just randomized each time
it does it changes it up a bit
oh see that one they went all stamina
what that's a terrible result right
there
okay I like that one with the powerful
jinx
oh dude
I don't need that much in the
I think that's I'm gonna start going
with stamina
yeah that's a good balance right there I
don't even really care about the accio
though
can I do another stamina I just want to
give him as much health these all just
Plus 10.
okay there's a plus 20.
new Tweet about incendio
all right
check it out right
we gotta check it out
all right here we go
okay hold on let's read the message
first set things Ablaze with incendio oh
boy
so it's kind of like uh looks similar to
what they did with imperio
obtain proof for Duncan ooh a new a new
uh character there
a new character obtain proof for Duncan
how will you cast incendio
poacher Ranger right there oh my
goodness look at all these enemies on
the map here
slice a poacher duelist while they're
casting reducto
slice
launch an enemy into a destructible
object with the pulso
oh dude these little dueling Feats are
gonna be so fun
looks like we have like a spider nest
over here
and then a noose I think that might be a
new symbol right there
use it on the spider webs said find The
Relic
so it's only an eight second clip but
man look at that
find The Relic right there
and look at this area they're exploring
dude that looks
that might be like the Sebastian mission
ancient magic Relic
yeah I didn't get the I didn't get the
critiques of empty empty world I did not
get that feeling at all
of what they showed
now do we know the detail of the
missions yet no
and if they're how in-depth they are but
I definitely didn't get the feeling of
empty
Relic an ancient wand perhaps
and
obtain proof for Duncan
so in this wherever we're at here we're
looking to obtain proof for someone
named Duncan oh my goodness look at the
dude look at the statues right there
they look just like some of the ones
from the movie
Evo Senpai what's up welcome yeah it's a
tweet the Hogwarts Legacy they just
posted a new tweet
it's very short it's just about incendio
but you you already know we gotta we
gotta break it down
we gotta break it down
yes I'd love to see that you can like
the Torches that's awesome
I love it
thank you guys for letting me know by
the way thank you
oh I love how Elwyn said new post and I
just I instantly knew Michael redeeming
to hydrate thank you Michael
oh and Shaw said it as well new HL tweet
movement for uh keyboard controls were
on the Arrow Z for accio oh so you could
X for Jinx C for spells like Wingardium
Leviosa
gotcha
by the way welcome to the new follows uh
I saw the little no with the follow
welcome and then Ned followed as well
if I miss those sorry sorry
not gonna lie in the poacher Ranger part
of it there's a butterfly that flew
across the screen against the sky for a
second thought it was a dragon
I know right and then we go back to this
then we go back to this
they say the name of the broom shop
owner
I think they said the name of the broom
shop
I don't remember if they said the name
of the shop owner though
I feel like we should be putting most of
our stuff into
stamina and Jinx
so yeah let's oh Hermione doesn't oh no
she does she does she does
let's go to the Plus 20. oh she doesn't
have any plus 20s
all right I'm cool with that
and then Ron all right Ron we we got you
some better cards now Ron
okay so I'm just I'm gonna accio I just
don't feel like set important
especially since I'm not too concerned
with the beans
oh Ron's got A plus 50 booster on
stamina
yes sir all right we ready now we ready
scrub work dude what is up man welcome
because this game you always wear a
track suit and a red shirt like Carrie
does I love it
oh wait did I do
oh yeah yeah this is the level I meant
to do right
oh wait how do I I think we might be
able to get this one right away
maybe not
oh no what do I need to do to get that
one
order the Phoenix best game easily is
that your favorite one
I liked that one I did enjoy that one
but I feel like chamber is still my
favorite
you gotta find a block oh darn it
all right so I this is not the level I
meant to do by the way but I think we'll
still do it because
I think I still have some
Shields to find here
when modding for the PC version starts
to pick up do a mod showcase for
Hogwarts Legacy I like it it's a good
idea
oh yeah I can tell a big difference in
our magical abilities
you tell a big difference
looks like he's an insidio to light
torches defeat enemies clear spider webs
black and path yeah Eagle Eye
yeah all those were confirmed in that
very very short clip there all right so
I don't see a block anywhere in this
area
this time next month we'll be playing
well not yet we'll have about three more
days
foreign
yeah the Order of the Phoenix and
Half Blood Prince they did that was when
they really finally started to make
Hogwarts
they they had a good beginning to it and
uh philosophers and then chamber
and then POA
okay so we can we can uh
ouch
dude
why can I not
I was hoping we'd be able to use that
herbivicus spell in a lot of these areas
like right here yeah yeah yeah
but all it really does is I think it
just gives you beads
yeah just beans a single
oh my gosh
obtain proof for Duncan someone framed
and sent to ask him and I love it
I love the theories already
no my guess is it's probably
I would think something related to like
getting someone out of trouble in school
maybe
dude launch it over there
I don't even know if we should go that
way
hey Nico with another 100 bits so
Nico thanks for the cheer my friend
Ray attire guys that'll take some
getting used to for a lot of people
that's Nico from over on YouTube for any
of you who uh tune into our live streams
there
who is Duncan right
Elwyn redeeming a posture check here
and a hydrate
man I thought this would be
see this is like when the like if the
game wasn't annoying enough the first
time you have to do a lot of this stuff
you have to do a lot of backtracking in
this game
why is it not like come all one launch
launch over there
there we go all right good good good
good good
oh there's the block there's the block
we needed guys we're gonna have to take
that a long way
at least four shields in the forest two
of which are annoying to obtain
foreign
oh man
and then waldermar with a cheer 200 bits
a waldermar thank you thank you my
friend
thanks for your support of the Stream
hold on
let's see I think you can turn that on
as a mod let's see if I can uh
all right okay we're gonna go emote only
for let's do until I get this next
Shield oh there we go Nico on top of it
dude
Nico on top of it
all right have fun spamming the emotes
guys
if we uh
I think I have nightbot set to where it
shouldn't time you out for spamming
that'd be pretty funny though if
everybody started getting timed out for
spamming emotes
yeah I got rid of the push-up one Nico
because in this in this new setup I just
don't have like room for it
he's like sure that's the only reason
no I really don't mind that one it's
it's good for me to get up and move
around a bit on stream
but there's just no room I wouldn't have
any room to uh
you guys couldn't see me I don't think I
mean there is a little room like to the
left of me here
gosh Harry just got knocked out by that
all right are we going the right
direction I want to make sure I'm going
the right direction before I
carry this thing all the way back okay
we are we are
all right so we'll stay in emote only
until I get this
this next Shield here
inspectors like no I can't give tips now
what do I do
all right so let's get rid of this one
let's get rid of this one because it's
just like
it's going crazy on Hermione right now
what excuse me let me
out Harry
actually guys this game really needed a
lock on button of some kind
it's not letting me all right so guys so
all right trio trio come on come on team
I'm over here
Ron just ignore that dude
yes there you go Ron all right now we're
just gonna bash this Cube into him there
we go
all right we're gonna send it over as
far as we can all right looks like
that's it
come on Hermione this way this way
all right cast it again
come on lift
it's working
it's working
all right we're almost there
we are almost there
I think the next the one I meant to go
for is the prefix bathroom one because
that one we saw exactly where it is and
I think we just needed the
the new spell
wow nice camera work right there
all right Ron
yep
all right come on Harry
oh my gosh Harry come on
he literally does like no jump
whatsoever
oh we got it let's go
all right Nico you guys can take the
emote only back off
that was fun
that was fun
and then I think I saw another uh
hydrate I think there was a hydrate in
there too at some point
all right so inspector if you're still
here inspector realistically
not downloading any saves or anything
how much more time do you think I would
need to be able to beat the game
emote only in this game
some kind of torture device
realistically how much time do would I
need to beat the game because I need to
eat lunch at some point I'm trying to
figure out if I want to eat something on
stream or if I want to just power
through and try to beat this
or if we stop and try to pick it up
another day oh no
no hold on hold on not yet Nico not yet
let's wait till we start the new level
let's wait till we start the level
uh there are two easy shields in the
beginning of herbology okay first of all
let's see how many more Shields we need
we need two more and there you go they
said two easy ones right at the
beginning of herbology
oh my gosh imagine inspector trying to
give tips with emote only
we did uh yeah Nico if if it's the Tweet
you're talking about yeah the incendio
we pulled it up and talked about it for
a bit
what's up Alicia can't believe we keep
streaming while I'm at work at well
today's probably the last day for a bit
at least in terms of this time because
I'm I'm back to my regular my regular
day job tomorrow
but good to see you here hope your hope
your new job is going well and guys
sorry about the new the new followers
are currently being
like overcrowded by people who donate
bits down there on the little scroll
so I don't know why that I'm gonna look
into that after the stream today
Eagle Eye with the twitch Prime
subscription yo Eagle Eye thank you so
much dude
thank you so much for the subscription
and now you enjoy all those emotes you
can use those here when we're about to
go emote only mode again because someone
redeemed that redeem their Channel
points for that and then you also get
ad-free viewing on the channel
as a subscriber
all right so they said that I've seen a
couple of hydrates so
I'm gonna get to work on this bottle or
this
this CL
why can I not say the right word I keep
wanting to say glass but it's not a
glass and then I was going to say cup
which is correct but then it was about
to come out as class
and streaming too much we streamed
yesterday morning last night and now
this morning
it's all running together in my head
all the words
don't want you to get a heat stroke
right
this game makes people brain fart so
it's understandable did you did you hear
my question inspector oh wait hold on I
think you have to unlock the second task
see how many Shields and call today okay
so after we unlock the second task
that'd probably be a good point to call
it I like that I like that that's a good
one
and then we'll have to we'll have to
finish it out one night this week or
maybe next week
all right so we need two more try wizard
Shields
some we already have a vote for early in
the herbology level there's an easy an
easy two
so I hate this level
but I'm gonna Trust
I'm gonna trust and we're gonna go in
and we're gonna try
we're gonna try it
all right hopefully please just carry
over my cards from before
because I like that lineup
I like that and I like that
all right so we're gonna try to find if
we spot both of them then that will be
oh wait you're right there is one that's
really close to the beginning
hydrate redeem will make new Jabba so
the the little redeems the hydrating
stuff those are free
you earn channel so the channel points
you guys earn those just by literally
watching the stream chatting in the
Stream then I think you you might earn
some if you if you subscribe or donate
or things like that super not super
chats over here bits over here
but you also earn Channel points
literally even if you don't say a word
just by being in the Stream you earn
Channel points why did it not start me
at the beginning
uh vivicus
all right Nico
no go through the gate wait this one
hold on hold on hold on
before we go e emote only
there's the two easiest ones okay
through the gate down here
this gate right here
holy I thought you meant he was he'd
spend like too much money on that that's
funny
all right let's see if we drop something
in here maybe
nope I just had to do that I just had to
try that see if anything would happen
oh yeah I don't remember this area at
all
okay there's one right there
all right so we need to figure out
so I think what we're gonna need
I think I see the vision guys I see the
vision all right Nico I guess we gotta
do it I guess now would be as good a
time as any somebody redeemed the emote
only
let's take it into emote only
for the next I don't know I'm gonna get
this one pretty quick so
another emote only we got back to back
emote only
I'm gonna have to increase the price of
that one
all right there we go
Nico might be working or something too
so I'm gonna do it here I think I can do
it if I go here
emote only boom there we go
all right guys have fun
have fun spamming the emotes okay that
was super quick that was super quick
thank you guys for pointing that one out
now we're just gonna go right back into
her biology because there's another
quick one there and poor poor inspector
is not gonna be able to chat and give me
tips on this one
I'm gonna have to find this one all on
my own I do know that inspector said go
to the right to start unless you're a
mod I know I know right the mod powers
on Twitch Elwyn you have the power
and we only need one more so we need one
more to unlock the
the second task
so we're going to go back into herbology
here
ooh Doritos man hey go for some Doritos
right now
we're just gonna stick with the same
setup that we've had
go right back in and hopefully this one
is just as easy
that one we spotted right away oh the
yeah and Nate hey that's those emotes
could be very useful for inspector I
could just be like go here nay
nay inspector replies
all right so I know we go through here
for sure
and then we already got
okay let's move this out of the way
oh no those dudes come in over here too
the angry red ones
popcorn Gigi's got the popcorn ready
all right I'm gonna go here
oh okay there's one I think this might
be the easy one
no
but there's three of these angry dudes
man good thing we upped our stamina
right all right so I think we have to
cast a jinx first
and then can I cast herbivicus on this
dude
oh wow
oh they just keep coming though
it's better just to ignore them
they just keep respawning
oh Ron's almost got this one
stand up Harry you got it you've got
this
all right
okay I mean I didn't want to aim for
that Lily Pad just yet but it's fine
I'll take it
almost there almost there
let's go
let's go that wasn't too bad new level
available try wizard task number two
try wizard test number two
all right I'll go ahead and play that
one I'll go ahead and do that one too
let's go ahead and do that level
and that went pretty quick so I feel
like to since we had back to back people
Redeeming the emote only go team yes
I'll leave I'll leave the emote only on
for another uh minute or two here
so now the positives of that the good
news
is we unlocked this one oh my gosh but
then you need 11. or to unlock the third
task
yeah that'll be a good place to stop
let's just go ahead and do this Mission
we'll probably get one for completing it
the second task last night something our
Champions value exceptionally it's taken
from them
that's something now lies
their mission this morning
is to retreat I can't believe they used
actual people for this mission right
actual humans
they knew what was happening but poor
Harry did not now in terms of levels
that are annoying this is the one that I
remember as being a pain from when I
played as a kid this is the one
oh man herbology was bad
let's see what what this one is like
though oh no we've got the the inverted
controls return
foreign
[Music]
it's like a it's like another broom one
what
I do not remember this at all
okay there's like a speed boost
collect Gilly weed okay but now we know
that the speed doesn't matter if it's
like the Dragon one the speed does not
matter
all we gotta do the jinxes on them in
here though
there we go
or is there even a high score thing
maybe there's not even a high score
thing on this one I'm just gonna assume
there is though since it feels very
similar
to the
Dragon level
I'm absolutely just spamming if you're
wondering 100 we're just spamming
I mean there's no there's no like real
way of aiming
I can't lock onto anything we might as
well just Spam them as we go right
foreign
way like to make this a timed
a time
a Time level
oh no inspector's getting frustrated
watch this one be based on speed though
this one's actually probably based on
speed
we're gonna have to do it again
oh no
okay he made it he made it through
good job Harry
okay what is this weird little camera
view we got going here
okay so you can you can't aim a little
bit now
it sort of shifts into this first person
view
semi third person you can still see a
little bit of Harry there
you guys are just joining in uh we are
in emote only mode right now
because some people redeemed that with
their Channel points
usually most streamers I watch use emote
only mode when chat gets like two off
the rails
with the conversation
so anytime I go into streaming they're
an emote only I'm like oh man chat must
have been being naughty
chat was being naughty causing problems
why didn't I hit that Gilly weed I was
right on it
oh dude what is this up here
this looks like something out of Eldon
ring what the heck all right so we got
our little
over the shoulder aiming view here now
oh no we're almost dead
get out of the way you grindelos
foreign
oh my goodness that was right in my face
what the heck
he's got like a little bit of a Dodge
we're at 10 Health man I really hope
chocolate frogs work underwater
oh
no I don't want to do it again
okay thank you for the cutscene
thank you at least we get to pick it up
right there
oh no wait yeah yeah we picked it up
right there all right we could turn
we're going to turn off the emote only
mode now
gonna turn off emote only mode
there we go back to normal
so now you guys can share in my
frustration
emote only is just as bad as slow mode
Alicia says
right
okay we can kind of aim right here
Oh I thought it I was probably just
gonna end it right there if we had to if
we had to go all the way back to the
beginning
okay so we do have a little bit of
control dude I'm already down to 60
Health though
all right inspector hit me with it
what's what's the goal here is it like
the dragon challenge
do you get rewarded at the end with like
gold or
yeah thankfully
thankfully there are checkpoints
oh no we're running low on health again
we got to do all right
yeah let's use the speed boost
so we're getting to this little area
with 50 Health that's not not good oh
you guess it's like the dragon okay I'm
gonna make sure we collect
all right so I'm not even gonna
I'm gonna focus on the grindelos
and I don't want that one to get right
up in my face again
how are we getting hit man we're at 40.
I think they just keep coming
I gotta clear the path
I know I have to clear the path but I
also want them to stay off of me
no
yes just go just go Harry destroy it
go
please let this be the end
please
no do not get I needed a cut scene to
trigger
I thought I was dead for real dude I
thought I was dead
dude what are those things
cluster of
bubbles
man there needs to be something in here
to restore health
I don't like the fact that I'm only at
20 oh another cutscene yes
here's the song Here's the song
to discover what we took
please don't make that a literal in-game
hour by the way please please please
do not
[Music]
okay so apparently speed boost makes you
also immune
I ran right into that grindelo
oh we're going this way for sure
oh no
does this hurt me
yes it does hurt
only only five though
oh my goodness the camera here the
camera
this is rough this is very rough
swimming confirmed
right here we go here are the gameplay
type moments you get to look forward to
if swimming is in Hogwarts Legacy
well wait what the heck
we're in that weird view again oh yeah I
think I'm gonna have to destroy
yep that's what I was thinking
yep I was I was about to make a comment
of like at least there are no grindelos
here but I knew it was only for a moment
I knew it was going to be short-lived
oh great and then look what we have to
look forward to guys as we keep going
down
you think this is just
you think this is it right here no
no no no
how many levels do we have to go through
how many tiers of this
in the debts below
all right so why is this one not
destroyed
why not am I not hitting it
there we go finally
Harry really enjoys that Gilly weed all
right so go ahead and start casting the
spell now before the grindelos get out
all right come on come on come on spam
spam spam spam spam I mean just oh no
we're at five health
it is just button mashing
at its absolute worst
always like an inverted control system
right now
come on Harry
all right dude this this like Bob and
weave thing we got going
kind of working out right now
it's kind of working out
just keep going in a circle area you got
this
you got this dude
okay we got an opening like why can't I
not just swim through that opening why
do we have to destroy the whole thing
no that grindelow was really close okay
good good good good good
please be the end
no I had destroyed it I have destroyed
oh wait and now it's back to this
cutscene
it destroyed it
oh my gosh man
I couldn't keep my little Bob and weave
going
oh my
we're gonna look on the bright side we
have 100 Health again
we have a hundred health
to work with here and this little area
right here is not too bad
hopefully we can get through this
without taking any damage
I definitely want to get the beans
because that's how we get the most
Shields out of this tri-wizard Shields
that we need
I wish yeah there should be another cut
scene after this part right here
oh there there was a little cutscene but
it I guess that one wasn't a save point
all right so now we got the strategy now
though
it's a strategy of just you just go in a
circle
you just keep going in a circle
oh look at that we already destroyed
that one let's go
just keep going in a circle
I'm not even like I'm not aiming at
anything man I'm just going in a circle
spamming the Jinx button
we got this guys
this level is the exact reason you hate
underwater levels in game so when people
are like Hogwarts Legacy swimming you're
just like no please no don't do it
don't put it in
oh look at that man the bobbin weave the
bobbin weave Circle strategy
pays off
no damage right there on that point
no damage at all all right let's do it
again here
all right start the big start the big
circle going here we go I'm getting a
little dizzy here
getting a little dizzy hopefully it's
not bothering you guys too much
but it is definitely making me a bit
dizzy
fishing on the lake for Hogwarts Legacy
hydrate
you guys really trying to do that to me
right now you try to do that to me right
now
we are underwater right
now I'll I will hydrate here as soon as
we clear this part
we got back-to-back hydrates redeemed
right there
all right come on come on come on there
we go let's go look at that look at that
no damage we even dodged that guy right
there
all right another cut scene let's go
hey there they are
here he's like oh no I'm not leaving
them both here you kidding me dude
bronze
excuse me get out of here with the
bronze
that was probably based on time
maybe that's what you were thinking
inspector I bet that one's based on time
yeah yeah
come on man
ridiculous
and not the spell either completely
ridiculous
but you know what we made it through
we made it through I'm just sad that I'm
gonna have to complete that one again
now at some point
you know what maybe I'll do maybe I'll
go through and get the do the back
tracking off stream
and then when we stream again I can be
ready to do the
to actually go to the next mission 10
more Shields oh that's gonna be so
tedious